bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
la france vit son deuxième confinement
depuis le 29 octobre saint quentin en
yvelines poursuit les mesures mises en
place dès mars dernier à travers
notamment le rule de l'institut de
promotion de la santé
l'agglomération soutient aussi les
entreprises et les commerçants les
services publics que s'adapte saint
quentin en yvelines à leur dure
confinement ou quel point c'est parti
[Musique]
saint quentin en yvelines re confiné
mais malgré tout le vivante que lors du
premier confinement habitants école
entreprise mais aussi l'institut de
promotion de la santé
plus que jamais à l'écouté du public ce
lieu c'est vraiment le lieu de la mise
en oeuvre des politiques publiques de
santé pour saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
c'est un lieu où nous avons pu maintenir
en accueil téléphonique généraliste ou
l'ensemble des saint quentinois pouvez
effectivement avoir des informations
concernant effectivement cette crise
sanitaire c'est un lieu aussi qui
héberge un certain nombre de partenaires
une vingtaine en temps normal et un
certain nombre ont pu continuer à
maintenir effectivement des permanences
soient distantes camp distant ciel soit
en présence je pense par exemple au
centre d'addictologie de l'hôpital
mignot qui a continué son activité
lité s a permis la distribution de
matériel dès le 1er confinement visière
créé par certaines entreprises des
territoires distribution de masques pour
les professionnels de santé
l'institut a joué un rôle essentiel
ça a été un lieu ressource notamment
pour tout ce qui était actions de
prévention et pédagogique autour des
gestes barrières donc sur le port du
masque sur la distanciation physique un
lieu ressource également pour les
problèmes d'addictologie
si ce service n'avait pas été maintenue
on aurait vu des embouteillages dans les
autres services hospitaliers l'institut
restent actuellement à l'écouté de tous
les publics
la permanence écoute jeunes maintenu je
pense que tout le monde a maintenant
pris la mesure de ce type de crise même
si on n'est pas l'abri d'un certain
nombre de surprises bien évidemment mais
là on est maintenant sur des
perspectives peut être plus long terme
je pense notamment à l'arrivée par
exemple d'un vaccin qui pourrait arriver
durant l'année 2021 et je pense qu'on se
doit aussi d'anticiper toutes ces
campagnes de vaccination maintenant lee
ps a aussi établi un lien permanent avec
les personnes les plus fragiles et
un an avec les ehpad autre préoccupation
du territoire les entreprises dès le 1er
confinement des mesures ont été mises en
place afin de les aider à traverser
cette période de crime
[Musique]
la crise sanitaire impacte fortement
l'économie les entreprises et notamment
les plus petites d'entre elles
l'incubateur ski cubes de guyancourt
accueille des créateurs de projets
percuté de plein fouet par la pandémie
et les confinements successifs d'une
sorte comme la nôtre on est confronté un
pragmatique de démarrage est clairement
la situation nous facilite pas la vie
[Musique]
on a fait le lancement commercial de
notre solution il ya quelques semaines
il était prévu de participer à des
salons professionnels agricoles un
premier en septembre
en novembre et en février notamment le
salon international du machinisme
agricole et tous ces salons sont annulés
heureusement on a trouvé un partenaire
qui nous accompagnent qui donc permet de
commencer à commercialiser auprès de
leurs adhérents
mais par rapport au plan que j'imaginais
alors au mois de mars avant le premier
confinement clairement ça remettra mal
en question le déroulé de nos activités
notre progression
créée en février 2019 artix comptes un
ingénieur en informatique en cdi et 3
d'alternants durant les deux périodes de
confinement olivier rocheau a vu les
loyers de ces locaux annulé par
l'agglomération qui possède l'incubateur
il n'a cependant pas pu bénéficier du
prêt garanti par l'état début novembre
il a déposé un dossier auprès de la
région ile de france pour bénéficier du
prêt résilience j'ai de bons espoirs
d'avoir une aide qui sera précieuse
parce que c'est véritablement ce qui va
nous permettre de maintenir l'effort
jusqu'au jeudi un vrai redémarrage
jusqu'à une période où on espère avoir
un développement commercial de 9 ans car
les partenaires d'ortie qs sont séduits
par le projet de la start-up olivier
rocheau ne perd pas espoir
ils n'ont pas du tout abandonnée sur la
police mais nous soutiennent pour sa
présentera entre dans cet article ce
s'approche la situation passe tendue
pour beaucoup de jeunes créateurs
beaucoup de difficultés pour les
entreprises
[Musique]
les porteurs de projets beaucoup ont mis
en suspens leur projet pour des raisons
qu'on peut comprendre et pour ce qui est
des entreprises qui ont déjà démarré
leur activité
la situation est compliquée ici au
niveau des start-up que nous
accompagnons nous essayons de de mettre
en place des outils d accompagnement
spécifique pour essayer d'amortir un peu
le choc des outils et des plans mis en
place dès le 16 mars dernier
l'agglomération a effectivement lancé un
plan de reprise de rolande de 2 millions
d'euros
e
avec plusieurs leviers d'abord nous
avons exonérés de loyer redevance tout
ce qui pouvait dépendre de nos
nos bâtiments publics et puis 50 ans a
largement participé au déploiement du
fonds résilience qui a été lancé par la
région et donc saint quentin a apporté
également une somme une somme non
négligeable pour aider je dirai au
déploiement des prêts 30 tpe ou
bénéficier de ce prêt de relance de 600
10000 euros au total
avec un remboursement étalé dans le
temps mais le soutien n'est pas
seulement financier en septembre dernier
l'agglomération avait mis en place trois
jours de testing au vélodrome à la
demande des entreprises
3000 salariés étaient venus se faire
dépister les agents de saint quentin ont
téléphoné à grand nombre d'entreprises
pour essayer d'évaluer leurs besoins
voir s'ils avaient des difficultés et
voir si on pouvait leur apporter de
l'aide et je crois que ça a été plutôt
apprécié actuellement certaines
entreprises envisagent des plans de
licenciement il reste toutefois
difficile d'avoir une visibilité sur la
crise économique à venir
pour l'instant on n'est plus dans
l'observation et la collecte de données
pour avoir un bilan le plus fiable
possible en fin d'année pour soutenir
davantage les acteurs économiques
l'agglomération innove
les rendez vous phares comme le skate
business elles sont conservées
celui ci se tiendra le 26 novembre mais
entièrement en ligne cette année
on fait en sorte de valoriser ces
moments là qui vont devenir important on
ne sait pas pour combien de temps on en
a peut-être que l'année prochaine on
sera toujours dans la même dynamique de
faire des choses en distance yale donc
il faut avoir les
bien développer les bons outils pour ça
et il est hors de question dans ces
temps de crise que l'agglomération
abandonne ses entreprises bien au
contraire l'incubateur ski tube cherche
de nouveaux porteurs de projets ces
derniers pourront profiter d'une
expertise et d'un accompagnement sur
mesure au sein de l'écosystème de 51 ans
et demi paris saclay aujourd'hui on n'a
pas de vie d'en finaliser bon on
constate mais sans grande surprise une
baisse de 20% de la création
d'entreprise c'est vrai que le contexte
s'y prête peu là où notre attention va
être pleine et entière c'est sur le le
chômage et la difficulté pour les jeunes
de trouver un premier emploi voire une
alternance
fin juillet un sommet requin a été
organisée aux promos paul et avec pop
school afin de sensibiliser les jeunes
aux métiers du numérique un secteur en
tension à la mi octobre
c'est un séminaire en ligne qui s'est
tenue à l'adresse des 16 25 ans 160
offres d'emploi étaient proposés près de
40 entreprises ayant participé à
distance afin d'échanger avec les jeunes
on a près de 13000 demandeurs d'emploi
sur l'ensemble du territoire
[Musique]
c'est une augmentation près de 25% sur
un an
et c'est une augmentation qui touche
principalement les jeunes
malheureusement et les chômeurs de
longue durée
donc on a des offres d'emploi qui
commencent à revenir mais pas encore au
niveau d'avant crise
et si certains secteurs redémarre les
services à la personne la santé le
bâtiment les métiers du numérique
d'autres secteurs s'effondrent comme
celui du tourisme notre ambition à saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est d'accompagner tous ces secteurs
qui connaissent une difficulté forte
avec tout un tas de d'action qui
continue qui perdure mais en s'adaptant
bien évidemment règles de confinement il
ya une veille une veille importante des
services pour savoir effectivement quels
plans sociaux impact quelle entreprise
également une veille sur toutes les
aides les aides de l'état on a médité
d'aider des brochures pour informer sur
tous les dispositifs qui existent
l'agglomération travaille également à
plusieurs chantiers d'insertion pour les
personnes les plus éloignées de l'emploi
à la verrière ces contrats d'insertion à
courte durée ont un aspect solidaire il
s'agit de confectionner des masques
redistribuer ensuite à la population
autre rendez vous annuel le ski emploi
en piste au vélodrome
il reste pour l'heure maintenus
mais déjà le territoire souhaite
anticiper d'autres constats le
télétravail à créer de nouvelles
habitudes et politique de management
peut-être un des impacts de cette crise
ça va être aussi de réinventer les
espaces de travail pour penser plus
espace de coworking pour pas que tous
fassent en télétravail les ont aussi
besoin de contacts faudra pas hésiter à
revoir un petit peu balou façon de
travailler est d'accueillir les
entreprises d'autres professionnels ont
pu bénéficier de soutien de
l'agglomération
les commerçants dès le mois de mars
l'agglomération a mis en place une
plateforme facebook dédiée aux
commerçants et aux agriculteurs le
groupe sky commerçants il ya eu vraiment
une montée des commandes au fur à mesure
c'est le site ce qui soutient ces
commerçants parce qu'en fait les gens
communiquent et partage énormément leurs
coups de coeur
on s'est fait connaître sur la page que
de l'athlète saint quentin cette page
facebook est donc suivi c'est donc et ça
fonctionne
c'était vraiment un énorme
un avant goût de l'expérience sur ce
site tous ont pu signaler leurs
activités aux saint quentinois
ces derniers ont pu se ravitailler au
plus près de chez eux
le site a immédiatement fait de nombreux
adeptes la plate forme est plus que
jamais active ces jours ci
les services publics s'adapte de nouveau
confinement
petit tour d'horizon les services
publics sont maintenus durant le
confinement les transports en commun
reste en activité
l'institut de promotion de la santé la
maison de justice et du droit
l'incubateur d'entreprises ce qui cube
sont ouverts l'hôtel d'agglomération
assure un accueil téléphonique
la collecte des déchets ménagers et les
déchetteries sont également ouvertes au
public les parcs et les jardins publics
sont aussi accessibles
le réseau des médiathèques propose un
service de drive
les habitants peuvent réserver en ligne
avant de venir à la médiathèque retirer
leurs réservations
certains sites sont désormais fermés le
musée de la ville la commanderie
la piscine intercommunale salvador
allende aux clayes-sous-bois
ce qui manque c'est terminé n'oubliez
pas d'appliquer les mesures barrières
nask distance ma propre de vous munir de
votre attestation pour tout déplacement
à très bientôt
[Musique]